[Music]
please
join me in welcoming jake thompson
[Applause]
good morning my name is jake thompson
i'm a senior psychometrician
at accessible teaching learning and
assessment systems at the university of
kansas
and there i work with k-12 assessment
data so taking
student test results turning them into
scores and then
the final step is writing technical
documentation to support the use of
those assessments
and the scores um that's what i want to
talk about today is a workflow
that we've developed for doing these
reports in our markdown
so before we get too far into it i do
want to acknowledge two of my colleagues
noelle pablo
and jeff hoover who've contributed a lot
to the work
both on the package and just thinking
about this workflow
and so noelle is here today so if you
see her be sure to say hi
jeff was not able to make it
so i probably don't need to sell this
crowd on our markdown too much
but i do think it's worth repeating why
we wanted to use our markdown for these
reports
um the first reason is that our markdown
reports are reproducible
and i mean that both within and across
years so if we have an analysis
and someone says where did this number
come from because we have the code
it's easy for us to say exactly where
that analysis happened
and how we got those results but then
it's also reproducible across years
so if you think about educational
assessment students test
every single year which means we have to
redo those reports every year with the
updated data
and so by using our markdown we can just
drop in the new data files
and then get the updated report for that
year so it ends up saving us
a lot of time secondly these reports are
dynamic so i think we've all probably
experienced an email that says
oh no we have an updated data file the
one you used is wrong
um but by using our markdown we can just
drop in that new data file
and get corrected results really quickly
and the other
reason is that we can get multiple
output formats with our markdown so we
can
write reports out to microsoft word or
pdf if we're using with tech or you can
even make
flash dex board or some slides or a
website
so the problem that we faced was that
the default look of
markdown report that you see over here
on the left does not really match
what our normal reports look like on the
right
and so often organizations atlas
included
have specific branding so we say if
we're going to make a report
this is what it needs to look like so in
order for us to use our markdown
for our technical reports we had to make
sure that it matched our brand
guidelines
and so today what i want to talk about
is how we went about
making these branded reports in a
reproducible
and scalable way
so the first step is to find your brand
and that can mean many things some
organizations have
a style guide or brand guidelines that
will specify
what fonts you're supposed to use the
colors spacing of the margin so anything
that is like
really annoying and gives you a headache
if you have to look at it for too long
that's probably what's in the brand
guidelines if you don't have that you
might have a marketing team
who puts together your reports for final
distribution
or you might even just have an editing
team so if you have someone who edits
your final
reports right before they go out they
are probably doing the little editing
stuff so you don't have to
and so you find them and that will help
you um
figure out what your final result needs
to look like
um step two is to then build your
template
um which is obviously not that easy it's
an iterative process that we're going to
talk a little bit more about
so basically you'll start a template
you'll render your document realize it's
not exactly what you wanted
make some tweaks re-render and so on and
so forth
until you get to that final version that
you want
and so today we're going to talk about
how to do this with a microsoft word
template because i think it's the most
straightforward
but you could do this with any type of
our markdown output
so i think the easiest way to do this
with microsoft word is just to start
writing your document in our markdown so
you can
start it just like you would any
document and then
once you get a little bit into it you
can hit that nip button
and what you'll get is an output that
looks like this and so this
is the default microsoft word template
if you don't specify any changes
and again this is nice but not exactly
what we want it to look like
and so what you'll do is you can click
your little cursor
into some section of the document so for
example if we were in the title
and then you'll click the styles pane up
top and there you'll see exactly what
style
the default template has chosen for you
and so if we are in the title
it'll say that we are in the title style
and then if we hit this arrow we can
modify that style
and so when we modify we can change the
font that's being used the color the
size the spacing around the paragraph
basically anything that you want to
change for that style you can modify
and then once you've done that you save
that word document
and that will be your template and so i
normally save it as
template dot dot x just to make it very
clear what i'm doing
and then in your microsoft or in your
our markdown yaml header
you still specify that you want to use
the word document but then you include
this extra option that says reference
reference.x
equals template docx so that template
file that you just saved
and so now when you knit that our
markdown document it's going to use all
those styles that you defined
when you're modifying those styles in
your word document
so there are a lot of different ways
that you can
modify styles in a word document to do
some really cool things
so these are some resources that i found
helpful when we were developing our word
templates
so daniel hadley actually gave a talk at
our studio comp a couple years ago
um called branding and automating with
our markdown where he
gives some really good advice about how
to do this um in word and some different
tricks about like how to get page breaks
by using
like a level six heading i think there's
also
a post on the rstudio website from
richard leighton called happy
collaboration with our markdown
to docx and then there's a chapter in
our markdown the definitive guide about
word documents
and all of these if you download the
slides
they are available at this address down
here
and i also at that website included
links to all these resources as well so
hopefully they're easy to access
all right so once we have our templates
you're not done
so your reports probably need a little
bit of polishing
so for example if you're including
figures you might want your figures to
also match your brand guidelines so use
the same fonts as your report
maybe have a color palette that matches
your brand's colors
and so there are some really good
examples about how to do this i'm not
going to talk about
ggplot themes on how to create them
today
that's kind of beyond the scope of what
i want to talk about here but
i did include some packages that i think
give some really good
examples for how to do this so the hrbr
themes package
and then also artistic and bb plot i
think do a really good job of
creating custom themes and then you also
might want to think about
i'm citing some default knitter chunk
options so if you think about how
big you want your figures to be in your
report if they need to follow a certain
aspect ratio
these are all things that you can define
as defaults within your
markdown document
okay so we have all of that we have our
templates we have our ggplot
themes the question is what do you do
with that
one option that we tried for a little
bit
was just having things live on a network
drive
i mean that got really messy really
quickly so every time you start a
project
you're then copying the templates the
code for the ggplot
themes all that into every project and
then if there's an update
you then have to go copy that into all
the projects to make sure everything's
using the most recent version of the
template
and it gets really messy and no one's
sure if they're using the correct
version of things and you have things
called
final and final underscore final two
and so what we did was we made we
wrapped it into an r package
and this ensures that if you have the
most recent version of the r package
you're always using the correct version
of the template it's easy to distribute
if you host it on github
and finally you can include
documentation so we have vignettes
included
that demonstrate to people who maybe
don't use our markdown that much
exactly how to write a report with this
how to include figures
and any other thing like that
so the package we created is called our
atlas
or ratlis and you can find
the code for this at the link for the
talk
so if you want to use it as a template
for your own organization please feel
free to adapt it and use however you see
fit
but this includes templates for
different types of reports that we
create
as well as some convenient project
templates which i'm going to talk about
in just a second
custom ggplot2 themes and vignettes for
documentation
so when you're creating this package
there
are several directories that i think are
important we're going to talk about
three of them
um two of them live in the ins directory
and that's the r markdown in our studio
folders
and then the r directory
so the our markdown directory is
basically just where your templates are
going to live
um so we have the inst directory
our markdown we defined that we're
making templates and then for
the rattles package we have two types of
reports that we make generally
we have topic guides and we have tech
reports
and so inside the topic guide we have
resources
and the template docx because those go
out as word documents
and then the tech reports get rendered
as pdf documents
so we have a latex template that gets
used there
so this isn't anything that is super
crazy
it's more just making sure that you have
structured your folders in a way
that makes sense to r and the functions
that we're going to use to wrap it
um and so that is our wrapper functions
that go in the r directory
and so ours is called render.r since
we're rendering the documents
and so this is the function that we use
when we're creating
a topic guide so we have
um the only arguments that get passed in
are the the dot dot dot
arguments and the first thing we do is
we
um just tell our what template we want
to use
so because we put that topic guide
template in the
inst directory we can use the system
file command to find that template
and then we just call our normal
rendering function
so the default in an r markdown document
is usually
a word document if you're
knitting to word here we use the book
down word document 2 function
because it has a bunch of other features
and functionality
that are useful for us and we just tell
it that we want to
use the reference docx we want to use
that template and then any other
arguments that got passed get forwarded
onto that book down function
and then this is also where we specify
our default knitter chunk options
so here we've said that by default we
don't want to show the code we just want
the
text and the results to show and we also
set a default
aspect ratio for our figures
and so now you'll call that function in
your yaml header which we have an
example of in just a couple slides
and so the last thing we tried to do was
make it easy for people to use
this package who maybe aren't as
familiar with r
or may not be as familiar with our
markdown and so
with our studio you can make project
templates
and so if you don't use projects i
highly recommend it i think it's a great
way to keep
your work organized but in the project
template
it also lives inside the inst directory
inside in our studio folder
again we're making a project template
and there are two
important things there's the topic guide
dot dcf
which is going to specify the name of
your template and what files you want to
open
and then also the resources for that so
what is going to be used
and so now if you go into rstudio and
click
i want to create a new project and you
can click the new directory
and now your project template will live
in this little
nice gui for users to click on and so
here we can click we want a topic guide
using ratlist and it will automatically
create your project for you and it will
open this
index file the index rmd file
that we've created so this is the
template rmd file that automatically
gets opened when you create
that new project and so it has the yaml
filled out
you can see here that we've specified
the output type as
ratlist topic guide x so that's the
rendering function that we just made
um and then it has like some default
bibliography settings
and it also includes a setup chunk that
loads some functions
and basically what we're trying to do is
just make it as easy as possible
for someone who's not as familiar with r
to access this workflow
so they can just click new project have
the document opened up and start writing
and not have to worry about
defining the templates correctly loading
in all this extra ggplot2 theme code
and things like that
so rylos is definitely not the only
example of this happening
there are many other examples that
we found very useful when putting our
package together
that i think are good resources for you
if you're thinking about making a
package for your own organization
so the sorensen impact package
i mentioned earlier daniel hadley gave a
talk a couple years ago
it was very similar to this one and they
use
the sorensen impact package there's also
the thesis down package
that does theses a latex
split for theses at read college by
chester izmi
and if you go to this repo in the readme
there's a link to about like 50 other
packages that have forked thesis down
for their own colleges or universities
so that's a really good place if you
want to see how to take an existing
package
and kind of modify it to meet your own
needs i'd really recommend going and
looking at that work
and then also the articles package wraps
a bunch of different latex templates for
rendering
our markdown documents to different
journal specifications
all right so thank you
a few minutes for questions and i see
there's already a few on slido so i'm
going to start here
the first one was can you get the css
out of a word
document template and then use it for
pdf or html
outputs so that's not anything that
i'm familiar with i think if you want to
go
to css or html it's probably better to
use one of those rendering functions or
look into the page down package which
will
define you can use css to define
pdf output that way
another question on slido was how do you
include logos
yeah so in your our markdown document
there's a function in the knitter
package called include graphics
and so if you have your logo in your
project directory
you can just say include graphics and
then the path to that figure and it'll
drop it in right for you
yeah great question great there's
quite a few coming in we have a few more
minutes so i'm going to go ahead and ask
can you knit pdfs using your docx
templates
uh no you have to have a latex template
if you're going to knit to a pdf
okay yeah do you have
any concerns with using an r markdown
document as a requirements document
for example using it for communicating
model racks and writing test cases
um i don't i personally use our markdown
for everything because i think it's
reproducible you can see exactly um
what you did in terms of code so i i
mean i would prefer that to a word
document
um so i'm probably biased and maybe not
the best person to ask but
i don't have any problems using our
markdown
okay and uh so there's two questions
left since we have a few minutes how are
you hosting and sharing these docs
so all of our documents get hosted on
the company website
so most of my reports that i write are
in support of the dynamic learning maps
assessment
so if you go to dynamiclearningmaps.org
there's a research publications page
where you can see all the different
reports that we've written
yeah so last question is what challenges
did you encounter
in the adoption of these templates so
the biggest challenge
was the first one before we had the
package and there were all these
different template versions running
around and no one was sure which one to
use
so i really recommend writing an r
package because
that is a really big headache
beyond that if you think about trying to
share it to
a broader company i really think
removing barriers for people who maybe
don't use ours often
so that's where those project templates
i think can be really helpful
if you can make it easy for someone who
doesn't know r or our markdown
to just open up a document and start
writing it's a much
easier ask to say learn some r markdown
formatting
like use double asterisks for bold as
opposed to
learn how to use r like that's a much
tougher ask that people are
going to give you some more pushback on
awesome thank you very much